quoique si nous bonjour à tous ici j'ai
l'honneur motors et je vous souhaite la
bienvenue à kapatakan cette semaine dans
mon reportage vous parle de lens
autochtone pour ce qui était tel peu
courant l'année 2020 2 marque le début
de la décennie internationale sur les
langues autochtones donc c'est une
opportunité de peut-être faire le point
sur os qu'on en est aujourd'hui dans la
protection et dans la survie des langues
autochtones et qu'est ce qu'on peut
faire pour les préserver et bien
évidemment moi en tant qu'autochtones
souvent quand je me présente aux gens
une des première question qui m'est
posée ici gs que tu parles est ce que tu
as envie de nous est ce que tu prends ta
langue et malheureusement même réponse
est non donc c'est un eiffel des
politiques assimilatrice des différents
gouvernements qui ont eu pour effet que
malheureusement la transmission de la
langue ne s'est pas rendue jusqu'à moins
donc ma grand mère du côté de ma mère le
parle couramment la langue est fait de
l'introduction est fait de l'animation
en langue innu malheureusement ça c'est
pas transmis pour différentes raisons
mais je connais quelques mots que
j'essaie d'utiliser
camp quand j'ai l'occasion de le faire
sont des présentations soit dans des
courriels que j'envoie le des fois ci
aussi simple que de dire queen pour dire
bonjour et tennis comme étonne pour dire
merci des fois ci c'est des petits
gestes comme ceux qui peuvent quand même
faire une petite différence au quotidien
mais
cessons dans le code ma communauté la
mme ashton viande ce suppôt seule dans
ma situation malheureusement aujourd'hui
à peu près seulement 10 % des individus
qui sont des locuteurs donc qui parlent
la langue à m'acheter brillante donc sur
une commune odile d'à peu près 8000
membres
ben ça fait que on a moins de 1000
personnes n'a aujourd'hui qui parle
couramment la langue et qui sont en
mesure de la transmettre par contre au
cours des dernières années mais il ya eu
des efforts quand même qu'ils sont mis
pour développer des outils développer
des programmes pour préserver la langue
auprès des locuteurs pour encourager la
transmission des locuteurs envers des
nouveaux locuteurs mais aussi pour
permettre à
à l'ensemble des membres de se
réapproprier leur langue et de pouvoir
la prendre donc au cours des neuf
dernières années il ya un module en
ligne un programme en ligne qui a été
développé pour qu'on puisse bien nous
les pekuakamiulnuatsh pouvoir suivre des
cours en ligne en de louer une donc la
langue innu et évidemment il ya d'autres
communautés un yacht aux premières
nations qui développe présentement leur
propre aux outils pour préserver leur
langue transmettre leur langue j'ai en
tête l'exemple des attikameks
dernièrement qui ont lancé le
dictionnaire attikameks donc deux
versions la version attikameks vers
français mais aussi la version français
vers attikameks une super belle
initiative et j'ai entendu parler de lui
dernièrement d'initiative du côté des
mi'kmaq il aussi sont en train de
développer des applications des
technologies pour rendre accessible la
transmission dame et se trouve ça super
intéressant quand c'est des applications
web quand c'est des applications mobiles
qui peuvent être utilisés
vraiment le parlement peu importe où est
ce qu'ils se trouvent parce que ça c'est
un des grands jeux l'accessibilité aux
ressources aujourd'hui on peut plus
seulement se permettre de développer des
ressources qui restent dans les
communautés mais pour penser à
l'ensemble des membres et dans beaucoup
de cubains les communautés autochtones
ont de plus en plus demande qui habitent
à l'extérieur donc c'est important de
penser à ces gens là qui ont peut-être
pas la connexion qui ont peut-être pas
l'opportunité d'être présent dans la
communauté mais que eux aussi plus avoir
accès à ces ressources là et je pense
que les technologies comme des sites
internet ou dans ce cas des applications
ben ça contribue forcément assauts
ensuite bien pour dire que y'a quand
même un enjeu qui est très important
c'est celui de la conscience est je
pense quand même si on développe les
outils qui que ce soit les meilleurs
outils qu'ils soient accessibles qui
soit intuitif si les gens ne sont pas
conscients qu'ils aient à l'importance
de préserver la langue mais je pense
qu'on passe à côté de quelque chose
parce que ces gens là mais même si ils
ont des outils à leur disposition s'ils
sont peu conscients c'est aussi ils
ressentent pas nécessairement
l'importance d'utiliser ces outils là
mais malheureusement cette fois très peu
de différence donc je pense que l'enjeu
qu'on en ce moment c'est de
conscientiser les membres des premières
nations à l'importance de préserver la
langue et il s'est vraiment encore un
c'est vraiment pas un dossier facile je
vais prendre comme exemple le prêt de ma
communauté un match tout y at
on eu de plus en plus de monde à chaque
année on a un nombre croissant de
membres qui est très très fort puis il
ya une réalité qui que beaucoup des
membres sont des gens qui habitent à
l'extérieur dans certains codes qui ont
une déconnexion peut-être avec la
réalité qui se passe dans la communauté
parce que ça fait quelques générations
qui sont peut-être coupés de leur
culture ben ça c'est un danger important
c'est d'aller rechercher ses membres la
puis entre l'ensemble des membres et de
se dire mais c'est important de
préserver nos langues puisque ça fait
partie de notre culture on n'avait pas
de le dire les langues autochtones ccc
des langues vivantes des langues qui qui
provient de la nature
cc c'est super image et comme façon de
voir le monde qui clairement mais ça
fait partie de notre façon de voir le
monde justement de notre façon de
communiquer donc je pense que c'est
important les préserver de faire des
efforts en ce cas pour les préserver et
j'espère que 2022 et la prochaine
décennie et plus encore mais ce sera
l'opportunité de faire ces efforts de
façon collective mais surtout de façon
individuelle de prendre conscience
individuellement qu'on est capable de
faire une différence et 5 seulement je
me donne comme devoir en commission 2
de
d'apprendre maroc de faire les efforts
mois marine pour mettre en pratique ce
geste là que ce soit quelques mots
quelques phrases d'usagé mais au moins
ce serait ce parce que ya pas de petit
effort tous les efforts qu'on dit si on
y met chacun des efforts individuels
mais collectivement sauf peut-être faire
une très grande différence donc j'espère
que ce sera une opportunité une occasion
on se ressaisir nous les autochtones
mais aussi les alliés autochtone pour
qui sept ans je jouais tous importants
donc voilà c'est de mes réflexions de la
semaine j'espère que vous avez apprécié
sur ce fut une excellente semaine à tous
et à bientôt pour un reportage